today I'm going to talk to you guys
about the past present in the future of
ipython and Jupiter we're also going to
talk a little bit about the differences
between Jupiter and I Python and in
doing that we'll explore a little bit of
the greater Jupiter universe so first a
little bit about me my name is Jonathan
Frederick I've been on the team for two
and a half years funded for two years
working full-time you guys can find me
on github or get er under the screen
name JD Fred ER for those of you who
don't know me I implemented a lot of the
interactive widgets in the notebook I've
also done a lot of the notebook front
end work and refactored NBD convert
which is the notebook conversion tool
just in case some of you guys don't know
what the notebook is I'll give a little
live demo first let me let you know
where you can find it so if you go to
Continuum's website and follow the link
to anaconda you can download and install
the notebook easily it's like a
one-click installer and for mac and
windows it will add a shortcut to your
desktop that you can double click to
launch the notebook if you're a linux
user or you just like launching things
from the terminal like i do it's pretty
simple to start the notebook just open
up your handy-dandy console and type
ipython spaced out book-running that
command launches the notebook server and
it will open the notebook in a new tab
for you the first page that you land on
is the dashboard I'll zoom in so you can
see that a little bit better the
dashboard is just kind of like a file
explorer it shows you all the files in
the current directory that you're in it
also shows you all the folders it sorts
by folders notebooks and then other
files on the dashboard you also have two
other tabs running in class
running lets you see what terminals you
have open and what notebooks that you
have currently running and clusters lets
you manage and launch clusters for
parallel computing so going back to the
files tab this new button here is how
you launch new apps so I can create a
new text file for example and it will
launch the text editor app inside this
app I can edit any type of standard text
file like i can write Python so def
hello just print hi you know that it
doesn't have any syntax highlighting
right now and in order to enable the
syntax highlighting you can just give
the file a name with the correct
extension and will automatically choose
the right type of syntax highlighting
for you but you can also explicitly tell
it what language you're using with this
language drop-down list additionally
from this new menu you can launch
terminals and so this is a this is a
standard terminal it's connecting to the
computer that's running the server which
happens to be this current machine that
I'm on you can do mostly anything that
you would do from a normal terminal you
can even launch applications like nano
or vin lastly and possibly the most
important feature is the ability to
launch notebooks from this page under
the notebooks menu item there's a list
of different kernels that you have
installed and so this is what language
the notebook will start with so i can
pick python to and then the notebook
launches the actual notebook application
so this is what the the notebook that
everybody talks about looks like at the
top here you have the name of the file
that you're editing the menu bar in
toolbar right below that and then inside
this gray area the white content is the
notebook
document itself what notebooks allow you
to do is embed narrative text alongside
your coat so for those of you who recall
academia or are in academia now you'll
know that the the standard method for
writing an academic paper involves
pulling up your favorite word editor our
text editor like word or libre office
writing some narrative content like an
introduction in a background and then
going into a separate program like
MATLAB or Mathematica to do your
analysis and then after you finish your
analysis you copy and paste all that
analysis back into your word editor and
format it well the notebook attempts to
solve that by allowing you to have both
interleaved so I can change the cell
type that I have selected the cell that
I have selected identified by a border
around it right now there's only one
cell in the document so i can change it
to mark down and that allows me to write
markdown text and if i do shift enter it
will execute that cell so it will render
it and then add a new cell the default
cell type is a code cell so that allows
me the right code in the current kernel
that i'm running in this case python so
i can print one plus three control enter
execute the cell in place so running
that you see that the output appears
right next to the text so going back to
the talk now that you guys kind of at
least know everybody should be on the
same page they know what the notebook is
I'll talk a little bit about the history
of the notebook so not too long ago
their only existed ipython ipython was
written by dr. Fernando Perez in 2001 as
a procrastination for his dissertation
I Python was great because it provided
many little features that the Python
repple didn't have like cap completion
pretty printing auto indent debugging
and introspection but there's one big
problem with it for scientists and
that's that it runs inside the console
so you can't output in line rich content
like charts and video and sound and
whatever yeah you can pop that out in a
separate window but it's it's not within
your document in late 2004 Brian Granger
and Fernando Perez were in the Bay Area
enjoying some ice cream they were
talking about parallel computing in
Python and the abstractions needed to do
parallel computing in Python it was then
that they realized that those same
abstractions could be used to allow
multiple front ends to connect to
ipython from this point forward the
dream of the notebook was born in the
summer 2006 min who's another core
developer wrote the third of five
attempts the right notebook interface he
used SQL alchemy as a back-end the store
the notebook content and z mq didn't
exist at the time so he used some other
network protocol zeem q is what we use
today they do our networking and because
of that the the abstractions weren't
quite right and the thing kind of
dissolved and further attempts replaced
it experiments continued until 2009 when
it was decided that Brian would
refractor ipython the factoring is what
laid the foundation for a kernel to be
abstracted out of ipython zeromq the
library that we use for networking was
released in 2009 Brian later in 2010
wrote and released a PI Z mq wrapper for
using zeromq from Python in the summer
of two thousand and ten min took over
the pies EMQ project that Brian started
in that same summer and thought wrote
the Qt console front end in Brian and
Fernanda abstracted the Python Colonel
out of ipython in September 2010 Thomas
clover joined the team he's another one
of the core developers he's not here
today in the summer of 2011 Brian wrote
the first version of the notebook we
have today and this is what that
notebook looked like so this this was
released in September of 2011 you can
see it doesn't really resemble the
notebook that we have today other than
the input and output prompts it's pretty
crude looking on the left you have a
bunch of buttons that allow you to
manipulate the document on the right in
September 2011 matisse bustier joined
the team and a year and three months
later I joined and around then many
others have joined from then until now
so are our teams growing rapidly over
the past few years I'm sure this isn't
everybody I just kind of ran out of room
on the slide so in 2013 ipython one
point 0 was released and this had the
ipython notebook in it the first
notebook that kind of looks like the
notebook that you guys have today so you
can see it has the same familiar menubar
and toolbar a little bit different
styling but for the most part it's it's
what you guys will recognize in 2014 you
release I Python 2 point 0 which was
another version another version of the
notebook was included this release
although it looks the same contains a
lot of new features like the interactive
widgets I talked about earlier command
and edit modes so this allows you to
quickly manipulate the document from
afar
manipulate move move cells around and
also have fine-grained control of each
individual cell and improve colonel
support in the kernel support the
improved kernels part was good enough
and our front end was language agnostic
enough that people started writing
kernels in different languages for the
Jupiter notebook or the ipython notebook
and this is one of the first kernels
this is Julia and so a pretty popular
colonel the notebook so now our name was
no longer fit because our name has the
word Python in it but we're really
trying to give this image of being
completely language agnostic and
friendly and open to new kernels being
written we don't want people going out
and rewriting the notebook either from
scratch or taking our notebook and
rebranding it we want to the unifi under
one umbrella so we came up with the name
Jupiter it's not really an acronym but
we like to pretend that the Ju the py in
the r represent julia python and r which
are kind of our three most popular
kernels right now the logo i don't know
if you guys recognize this this is
Galileo's drawings of Jupiter and three
of its moons the logo was inspired by
this so if you if you take it and kind
of rearrange it a little bit you can see
it looks looks like our logo that we
have today with this new branding we
released I Python 3 point 0 which
contained the Jupiter notebook so this
is the first notebook that was branded
as the Jupiter notebook and in this
picture if if you guys are familiar with
Python hopefully because we're at a
Python conference you you are the
language there in that cell is not
Python and if you look at the top right
you'll see that it says julia 0 dot 3
and that's because this is actually
running a julia back end this is not
running on my local machine this is
actually running on temp NB which we'll
talk about a little bit later
you can tell because of the little
Rackspace logo in the top right-hand
corner there the notebook but there's
still one big problem literally one
colossal problem and that is that we
were doing all of our development in
that same ipython repository that we
worked on the original ipython
application so all the notebook stuff
the colonel stuff everything was just
cram Jack cram cram packed into this one
repository this made it really hard to
manage and not very modular so our
solution to that is what we call the big
split and that's what we're doing for
version for dot oh I was hoping that
version for data would be out by this
weekend but I was misinformed it's going
to be a little bit longer maybe a month
or so but I wouldn't bet anything too
important on that because you never know
what these kind of things so the big
split of what we do is we're taking all
the components of the Jupiter notebook
and actually moving them into separate
repositories to the user for you guys
not much will change maybe a couple more
bugs but but I mean in the long run this
is good because this will make it easier
for us to manage and hopefully we'll be
able to shoot features out to you guys
quicker Bob tank late la tech support
yeah has la tech support yeah the
notebook has a lot of tech support at
the end all open the floor for questions
so I want to take a second to reflect a
little bit on our progress this is when
we started using github at the far left
here in 2005 right before 2012 is when
that first crude looking notebook was
released and in between 2013 and 2014 in
is when we released the first version of
the notebook to the left of the crude
version of the notebook that was
released you can see that the slope of
the cumulative amount of commits over
time as dramatically increased and I
think it's about then that Brian started
writing this notebook and it started
picking up steam because once again this
green line is when it was released not
not necessarily when it was when it
started getting ridden zooming in taking
that notebook portion over to the
left-hand side of the graph we can see
that between the notebook in version 1
point 0 there was a big piece of time
and between 1 point 0 and 30 there's a
lot less time so we're making releases
quite a bit quicker to the right of the
30 line you see a little bit of a
plateau and that's the effect of the big
split we're not being lazy here it's
just that my statistics are only looking
at the ipython ipython repo and a lot of
commits are being done in other
repositories so this is a bad plot 430
into the right so today these are our
institutional partners we are working on
getting the big split out we're also
working on refactoring our front-end as
a part of making everything more modular
so we're using a library by Chris
culbert called phosphor Jas it's a
high-performance UI web kit and we're
going to be redoing each piece
the notebook so you guys that want to
write custom applications based on the
notebook will easily be able to take
pieces of the notebook and embed them
inside your own web apps luckily we're
funded by a big grant this is what pays
me and all the others on the core team
this is also what is going to kind of
drive the future of the notebook so with
that being said I just want to say we
are hiring if you like a fast pace fun
work environment that's kind of like a
start-up I talked to Brian Fernando or I
at Cal Poly we're hiring two software
engineers one project coordinator and
one full-time designer at UC Berkeley
we're hiring two postdocs one technical
project manager and one admin which will
be working half time on the Jupiter
project and the other half time with
bids that berkeley institute for day
designs so i want to take us a little
bit of time to talk about the grant and
what deliverables we have for the grant
because this is really what's going to
give you an idea of what's coming in the
future of the Jupiter notebook so the
grant deliverables are broken down into
four categories three-fourth of them
have capstone projects we have
interactive computing collaboration
computational narratives and
sustainability sustainability is just
how the project will exist beyond the
life of the grant you can read the full
grant at this tiny URL that I posted at
the bottom it's just tinyurl com 4 / JPY
for Jupiter grant so each of those four
sections has a sub sections and each
subsection kind of has main points which
will cover so under interactive
computing modular reusable ui/ux we're
going to do a couple things one we're
going to break the note put app into
components we're going to do UI UX
usability
these create a richer set of actions for
you guys so you can manipulate your
notebooks easier for example multiple
cell copy and paste for software
engineering this is this is a point that
hits close to home for me because I'm a
software engineer and usually when i'm
using the notebook it's for data science
ii kind of things or for teaching a
class but not in my everyday work i
don't necessarily use the notebook to
work on the notebook beyond using the
notebook to look for bugs in the
notebook so we're going to do some
things that kind of allow people to use
notebooks for software engineering or at
least help in that process the first is
we're going to ease the transition from
large notebooks and the small notebooks
so taking these big monolithic notebooks
that you have in taking some of the
cells out and putting them in separate
notebooks the second is we're going to
make notebooks in portable as packages
so this really applies to python
specifically different languages will
have to implement that ourselves third
we're going to add notebook testing
tools so like unit tests in the notebook
ways for you to verify that your
notebook is working correctly and we're
also going to create a tool to verify
that your notebook is indeed
reproducible so we talked a lot about
notebooks encouraging reproducible data
science the next big point under
interactive computing is notebooks as
interactive applications and what this
is is a lot of widget work so right now
we provide the widget framework that was
talking about earlier but we're going to
take that a step further and allow you
to use the widgets outside of the
notebook so you'll be able to use
widgets to build custom web applications
this includes adding a tool that will
allow you to easily deploy these web
applications
and the capstone project for the
interactive computing and this is really
kind of like a stretch Bowl if if we can
get to it we're going to try the tackle
the spreadsheet problem under
collaboration we have NB convert as a
big point we want to write an ePub
exporter which is like an HTML based
document format that publishers like we
want to refactor the command line API
and programmatic API for easier
customizability we want to improve the
documentation because we know the
documentation is lacking in that area
and use and be convert to do some of our
documentation to write our documentation
in notebooks and lastly we want to try
the right a Microsoft Word exporter the
next point on the collaboration is
element filtering so we want to add a
way that you can add arbitrary tags to
your cells and then a UI that allows you
to easily filter those cells so in your
large monolithic notebooks you can tag
things as like part 1 part 2 or relate
it to a thing x and then you'll have a
little R with a special syntax that
you'll be able to say like x and part 1
and it will just display the cell let's
X in part 1 the next point under
collaboration is documentation we're
going to write more documentation and
notebook based documentation the
capstone for collaboration is to
actually use all these things that we're
doing for collaboration with actual
publishers
actually I got my titles screwed up
their computational narratives was
supposed to be on that first part
collaboration is supposed to be from
here on out sorry I just realized that
so under collaboration the real
collaboration not computational
narratives we're going to work on real
time collaboration modeled after Google
Docs so this will allow you to work on
notebooks with your friends and I think
this is a really exciting feature we've
been trying to experiment with this for
a while but the big split and our work
with redoing the front end is kind of
conflicting with this because this is
really a full front end project so the
next part under collaboration is Jupiter
hub we're going to add fine grain
sharing controls create tools that ease
in the the deployment of Jupiter hub
because if any of you have actually
deployed Jupiter hubs Jupiter hub at
your institution you'll know that it can
be a little bit painful there's a lot of
steps involved and we're also going to
allow add a new feature the Jupiter hub
that allows the users to publish their
notebooks to each other and on the
internet for the capstone of
computational of collaboration we're
going to work on the integration of
real-time collaboration in Jupiter hub
so before i get into the greater jupiter
universe I want to just reflect for a
second on what the difference between
Jupiter and I python is so I Python
still exists it's that same terminal
application that you love there's also
the ipython kernel which is something
that the Jupiter notebook in other
Jupiter clients connect to to execute
Python code so the Jupiter itself is a
bigger org that represents all
front ends that connect to different
Jupiter kernels which could be you know
I Python Colonel I Julia colonel etc so
some of the larger projects in the
greater Jupiter universe like beyond the
notebook is NBD convert and be viewer
Jupiter hub temp NB phpbb and be greater
sidecar hydrogen and our mini mini
kermes so the first tool on my list is
NB convert this is a notebook conversion
tool it allows you to take your
notebooks and convert them into whatever
format you want here in this this little
animated gif I'm converting a notebook
into restructured text and then I dump
the restructured X to the criminal this
just so you can see that it actually
worked at the bottom of each slide I'm
going to have the links to the project
so if there's anything that interests
you you can go check out the github may
be downloaded and contribute we like
contributions and be viewer it's a tool
that we have that allows you to share
notebooks with people that don't have
the Jupiter notebook installed so I'll
go ahead and give you actually a live
demo of this so as long as your notebook
is available somewhere on the internet
publicly you can share that notebook
with your friends so I'm going to take
the note book that we wrote earlier I'm
going to give it a name that's easy to
find on my file system and I'll sign on
to github it's a little small but it
doesn't matter if you can read the text
or not here the important point is me
taking that notebook see if we can find
it
so this aah I pyenv I'm going to take
this notebook and drag it on to gist
github com and I'm going to create a
public gist I can then take the URL on
the top of the address bar copy it and
go to envy viewer I python org I can
paste that click go and it what it will
do is it will render a static
representation of that notebook so I
can't here let me zoom in for you I
can't execute this code here it's just a
static representation and this is
something that you can then take this
link at the top in your address bar and
send it to your friends your friends
that don't have the Jupiter notebook
installed the next big Jupiter project
is Jupiter hub which is an authenticated
multi-user notebook environment what
this allows you to do is have multiple
users use the same server to run Jupiter
notebooks and the identification is
pluggable so if you have a different
antenna fication model you can put that
in like to integrate with your school's
identification for example or whatever
your corporate identification is once
the user logs in with their credentials
they are then able to launch a single
user notebook server and that's that
process runs under their credentials so
it just has all the permissions that
they normally would have the next big
project is temp NB this is what I use to
make the screenshot earlier this is a
service that's being ran by Rackspace
right now thanks to Kyle Kelly this is
something that allows you to launch a
from ephemeral notebook servers so you
can go to 10 or tribe Jupiter org and
what it will do is a little spawn up a
notebook server for you on the spot
really quickly we're using
hard to do that and I think Kyle does a
lot of magic to get it the work that
fast here you can see it in this little
loop gif I'm opeing a Julia notebook
another interesting project in the
Jupiter org which is kind of new is
phpbb this is something that O'Reilly
has been working on what it does is it
allows you to integrate pieces of the
notebook into your static web page using
javascript so this is just a normal
normal web page and they use the feed
API to actually add a cell which then
you can run the cell and even
interactive widgets work with feed so
it's a really cool way the to take some
example Python that you have and embed
it on your website this is the kind of
thing that our refactoring and redesign
of our web front-end will make easier
because you'll actually be able to use
real Jupiter notebook components instead
of have them having to rewrite
components from scratch another big
project that's getting a lot of motion
right now is n be greater this is useful
for people that are teaching classes
using the notebook it allows you to
create graded assignments and then
publish those to your students and
collect them and it has tools for
automatically grading those assignments
and then allowing you to manually grade
the assignments here you see the arrows
pointing to the drop-down that will let
you choose to use the NB grader create
assignment tool bar this is kind of what
that looks like that toolbar here I'm
creating a question that is
automatically graded that it gets tested
against once the user writes the answer
another kind of fun project is sidecar
this is written by Kyle who's an
audience today and this allows you to
connect to a Jupiter kernel that you
have running and display rich output
from that Colonel so if you like the
interactive you know terminal type
experience but don't want a full-blown
notebook to get rich output you can use
sidecar to render rich output another
really cool project is hydrogen this is
something done by will Whitney I think
it's relatively new this allows you to
use Adam as a front end for Jupiter so
you can use atom with nye python kernel
or Jupiter sorry Julia kernel and
actually execute the code in Adam on the
fly so here's an example of some Python
code being executed lastly but
definitely not least important we now
support 47 different languages every
time we give talks like this this number
is increasing and increasing and
increasing we have a Wikipedia page that
people just add their kernels to you it
is it is below go below I go so I'm pop
pop left there and I would like to say
thanks we're giving out free t-shirts
the num focus booth later once again my
github is JD Frederick on tact me and
I'd like to open the floor for questions
yeah in the back
what we're doing with Microsoft what the
collaboration is Microsoft has given us
funding in the past the work on the
Jupiter notebook in fact that's what
funded me for the past year or so so we
kind of maintained a close relationship
with them I can't talk too much about
where the future of that is going I
would have to defer that to brian or
fernando who are in the audience back
there
here in the middle right
yeah totally so I think I forgot to
mention that on the my little brief
slide on Jupiter hub but the you can
actually plug the the spawner system is
pluggable so you can plug in like a
docker spawner and it will launch the
notebook server in a docker container
you could use any other kind of
containerization you want it with that
I'm just aware of the dock responder for
sure I don't know Kyle do you know if
any others exist there's
yeah so the way you do it now Dante like
their phone directories volume in either
to an NFS or something else or even just
cooking out
the entire NV score
our version
ah there was a question in the back way
way way back there you might have to
yell okay oh yes that's part of the
software engineering yeah yeah no no
definitely that is something that I've
experimented with a little bit but the
project does plan on adding that
officially so yes definitely better
debugging support up here in the front
yes so right now we have a few in turn
to our hired one of our interns is here
actually right in front of you uh-huh
and one of our interns is working on
creating a spreadsheet work widget at
first which is just like the interactive
widgets that that I worked on earlier so
you'll be able to use it inside the
notebook but later we're planning on
experimenting on actually having a
spreadsheet app so like not the notebook
a different app that connects to Jupiter
kernels and allows you to do
spreadsheets type of things like a
standalone application Excel like thing
yeah yeah exactly yeah any other there
in the middle
what kind of integration is planned for
them I don't know but two of their
employees work with us one of them is
actually a core developer so that's why
they're an institutional partner I do
not know any other questions no
I think that's it then